Good morning Hank, it's Wednesday.
Guess what we're doing.
-I know, the pizza cocktail thing.
-We're making some pizza cocktails!
We're using my Pizza John shot glass and then this glass from the hotel because Hank forgot his Pizza John shot glass.
I did.
Okay Hank. First, I need some V8 juice, some vodka, a mozzarella stick, and a pepperoni.
It's a super modern take on the Bloody Mary.
-I hate Bloody Marys, by the way.
-Oh, me too.
It's one of my least favorite cocktails.
You tear it like this and then put it on the rim of the glass.
The mozzarella stick and the pepperoni, I think are mostly for garnish, but...
You can stir with the mozzarella stick as well
-That's bad.
-It did not taste good.
-Chaser!
The mozzarella stick's pretty good, though.
All the stuff you don't want goes in there.
Boy, that looks exactly like puke.
[laughter]
Our next cocktail is called the Tipsy John Green.
Hank, I need some Diet Dr. Pepper and vodka.
So, easy-peasy.
Clink!
-That's good.
-It is good.
That's the best Diet Dr. Pepper I've ever had.
That's the best vodka I've ever had.
The Old-School Vlogbrothers Joke.
It's equal parts champagne, Dr. Pepper, and Strawberry Hill.
But they didn't have Strawberry Hill, so we're going with Mike's Strawberry Lemonade.
-Here's to the species continuing into 2018.
-Boop!
Small pleasures.
-Really good!
-Amazing!
-Oh my god!
-One of the best champagnes I've ever had.
-A++
That's like the best way to have Diet Dr. Pepper, the best way to have Mike's Hard Lemonade, and the best way to have champagne.
I'm sorry, excuse me while I pour myself another one.
-How do you make Ovaltine?
-How do you MAKE Ovaltine?
-Yes.
-I don't know.
Hank, our next cocktail is called The Hank.
One part Strawberry Hill, which in this case is Mike's Hard Lemonade, one part vodka, and one part Ovaltine
because you made an Ovaltine joke in the previous video, so you're the reason we're in this problem.
Maybe I made a mistake.
Beautiful, like, striations in John's. Look how pretty it is.
Show it with the Pizza John out, so people know that there's value in that...
Ahh...the remote control!
-Cheers to...calzones!
-To calzones.
Not good.
This is a very good one, it's called Keep it Simple,
and it's just a shot of bubbly water.
Pour yourself a double! Hey, cheers!
-Here's to Willis Carrier.
-Willis Carrier!
-Long may he live.
-Mmmmm.
-Oh, that might be my favorite of the night.
Wisconsin!
-Hank, we are down to our last drink of the 2017...
-I feel like I'm flying like a G-6.
-The guy who created the periodic table also created vodka?
-He defined vodka
-Seriously?!
-So, yeah.  He was a Russian and he created the definition of what vodka was.
Hank, we've gotta get to our last drink of tonight,
which is...
It's called the Vlogbrothers classic.
It's Strawberry Hill with a Peep on top.
What flavor do you want? Do you want marshmallow ghosts, or do you want spooky...cats?
Just for future reference, Peeps don't have flavor,
they just have shape.
We don't have Strawberry Hill, but we have Mike's Harder Strawberry Lemonade.
-If you weren't completely incapacitated by the two and a half units of alcohol you've had...
-I'm at three now.
You would understand the incredible importance of pitching DFTBA merch during Pizzamas.
We don't have to! it's such high-quality stuff.
People will get it whether we talk about it or not.
Oh!  I mean, that was almost my favorite drink of the night.
Hank, get a hold of yourself, for God's sakes.
The winner and the person who's gonna receive all the Pizzamas merch is the Old School Vlogbrothers Joke.
Equal parts Strawberry Hill, champagne, and Diet Dr. Pepper.
-It was good!
-It was delicious.
I want to fill up bottles with it and sell it on the black market.
I wouldn't go that far.
Hank, thank you for being here.
Get some rest, and I will see you tomorrow